comme promis hier inauguration
officielle aujourd'hui de la chapelle
sixtine du vatican dont les peintures
ont été re ne rénové 13 années de
travail pour rendre sa splendeur à
l'oeuvre de michel-ange jean paul ii a
lui-même présidé cette cérémonie
précédée d'une messe de rome le
correspondant de france 2 alain chalon
après 14 ans de travaux la chapelle
sixtine retrouve sa splendeur originelle
dernière est plus difficile étape de la
restauration
le jugement dernier cette gigantesque
fresque de 180 m² a été dévoilée ce
matin par le pape au cours d'une messe
solennelle en mondiovision le jugement
dernier avant restauration s'étaient
cela sombre et opaque
aujourd'hui les couleurs ont retrouvé
leur vivacité et leur délicatesse le
travail de nettoyage
l'effacement des couche de colle des
traces de fumée de suie permet de
redécouvrir les détails des 300
personnages de la fresque
de jésus éphèbe imberbe plein de force
et de beauté aux damnés qui croupissent
en enfer au milieu des démons
michel-ange qui sait portraituré lui
même ici dans une expression d'effroi
amis c'est encore peindre ce jugement
dernier sept ans c'est à dire trois de
plus que pour l'ensemble de la voûte
cette voûte sublime de 800 m² à 24
mètres du sol lorsqu'il pas le jugement
dernier michel-ange à vannes 2 ans de
plus il est dans la soixantaine il
exprime ses craintes ses angoisses ses
fantasmes très crûment sans pudeur trop
crûment parfois aux yeux des princes de
l'église 40 corps nus sont ainsi habillé
au fil des ans les restaurateurs leur
ont rendu lorsque c'était possible et
autorisée par le pape leur nudité
originel ici par exemple pour
saint-andré les esprits chagrins vont
sans doute encore regretté la chapelle
sixtine d'autrefois et rouvrir la
polémique mais les experts sont formels
pour moi c'est absolument certain que ce
que l'on voit c'est ce qui a été pas par
michel-ange
est ce qu'il ya de certain c'est qu'il
n'y a pas eu de peinture qui était monté
sur les chapeaux de rage pour faire
depuis qu'elle est en vérité une simple
visite devrait suffire à clore pour tous
la police